I just saw a Carrot Top Show recently
how was that I loved it we uh had him on
the podcast and yeah it was fantastic
and it performed like
bananas yeah I mean not bananas but
performed well yeah it was it was how
[ __ ] jacked is he not So Much Anymore
oh he toned it down yeah he went crazy I
was like Steve brought it up and I
probably want to broach the subject this
is something by the way that is going on
more and more
where I can't say somebody I can't
because of the fact that
they were so adamant
where like someone some dude's getting
like super crazy jacked and they're like
I don't want to talk about
right that and you're like okay but
it's like yeah I brought it up with
Karen top and he said he said yeah the
camera adds 10 pounds or something
but here's the thing like these dudes
like the most famous dudes in Hollywood
right in in in like action movies and
[ __ ] Chris Hemsworth Hemsworth the rock
yeah the rock is Juiced to the gills and
you're like he's fifth 48 yeah he's he's
well over 15 out of the road oh really
and but here's the thing man like when
you're when you're this size when you're
he's like six four six five and you're
265 of just muscle no body fat and I
mean you're chiseled
like you you know you're the the the
human body doesn't just like naturally
do this except for in like the most rare
spectacular cases right Francis nangana
exactly something like that but what's
weird is like the complete reluctance
to say like yeah I am I'm juicy it's
like hey kids this body takes half a
million a year to get to like why not be
he's exactly 50.
50 years old right and like you know you
know 50 walking around like that is
crazy but what I'm saying is like
why why are we pretending first of all
there's a couple of things like if you
think that if you just got on a cycle
you're gonna look like the rock you're
out of your goddamn mind right it takes
like an incredible amount of work and
dedication and discipline to get there
but why are we all pretending right all
these dudes aren't on [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
crazy and they are like don't talk about
it right all right and
um what uh
I think this came out on the Netflix
show killer Sally which which I quite
enjoyed they said that there was like a
bodybuilding competition and then all of
a sudden they they made it mandatory no
steroids for like two years and like
visibly like they just weren't so
impressive anymore and they were like
okay screw that we're back
nobody wanted to see these guys there's
a lot of these dudes that are like you
don't just don't talk about the fact
that I'm on [ __ ] and you're like it was
one of my favorite things when I um
you know who Mark Bell is Mark smelly
Bell he's like uh he was a world-class
power lifter now he's like a fitness he
developed a slingshot which is this like
yeah thing that you know you can helps
like bench press
and like when I first met him I was like
we were looking at like these photos of
him doing these crazy power like 1200
pound squats and [ __ ] and you're like
Jesus [ __ ] cry like and he's like
well you know I'm on like 20 Peds like
you know like I'm I'm on all this [ __ ]
but like here's the thing so he's like
yeah I'm on that [ __ ] but also like you
also go like yeah you know that if you
took that [ __ ] you're not squatting that
like the guy right it's a combination of
the thing but he's not going
oh I never took anything like the people
live in this fantasy of like
yeah own it yeah like Schwarzenegger is
like yeah we all did steroids that's
what we like when people were like you
just stare he's like we all we all did
them like do you think that if you did
steroids you would look like Arnold
[ __ ] Schwarzenegger like it's not
it's not that easy man part of me thinks
that it should be a requirement for
professional athletes to take
performance enhancing drugs I mean who
doesn't want to see an enhanced
performance I mean I mean dude baseball
in like 2006 when like Mark Maguire
Barry Bonds and Sammy Sosa were crushing
home runs like that was the best time in
baseball it's the only time I've ever
watched baseball yeah exactly I can't
stand baseball I just want to see them
[ __ ] crash home runs yes I want to
see people Roid Rage and like break bats
over their [ __ ] head or knee or yeah
like get pissed and throw Gatorade onto
the field and but like for instance
that's an anomaly Bo Jackson that's a
guy that could do that [ __ ] steroid free
he's a freak of nature he can run
sideways on walls yeah that's a once in
a generation type of person but
everybody else is probably looking at
like how do I do that steroids yeah
nobody's broken a bat over their knee in
a long time have they not that I've seen
he did that [ __ ] with ease I know dude
imagine that you have to be like he
would do it like it was a twig he was
like damn and just like snap a bat over
his knee yep who knows man I would love
and then you wouldn't play football yeah
they said that he would show up to Camp
right and Camp is like grueling and it's
when you you think you're in shape right
like players will stay in shape then
they get the camp and they're like I'm
not in game shape you know and that Beau
would show up like three weeks late to
camp
and right out of the gate would just be
blown by ever they were like
like it was like he didn't even need
Camp That's crazy dude it's called
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on Amazon and type in Stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and Order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're at
ranked number 30 on all of Amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on Amazon and buy Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude